and what's way cooler Michael than 2009
or 2011 is the world is ready to
understand the biggest truth which is
the elephant in the room in Madison
Avenue which is brand is built in Social
through scaled relevance to many more
consumer segmentations than television
and programmatic digital has been able
to afford us and that the creative
variable to put into those pipes and a
modern comms plan not based on
Impressions and grps is required and
that is an atomic bomb to what we've
been taught for the last 40 years and I
believe that I am stunned by how many
CMOS and more importantly CEOs of these
companies are starting to get to that
realization and that is going to be the
great reset of this industry I think of
the next decade
hello and welcome my name is Michael
wertzman I'm the global vice president
of programming here at advertising week
and I'd like to thank our virtual
audience for joining us today I'm really
excited about this session it's
something we do every year it's a
conversation that we call ahead of the
curve and it's exactly that we identify
someone who throughout the course of
their career has been consistently ahead
of the curve I really can't think of
anyone better to have this conversation
with than garyvee so Gary vaynerchuk
thank you so much for joining us today
really really appreciate it I'm humbled
and honored thanks for having me
of course of course so let's go all the
way back you got your start actually
stocking shelves at your parents liquor
store and in 96 you rebranded renamed it
and you launched one of the first and
and certainly one of the most successful
e-commerce liquor stores in the country
at the time this is really early in
the.com kind of bubble and boom but it
worked out for you so back then when
everyone was doing it and you you stood
out what what's the biggest takeaway you
had from then and what's the lesson that
really sticks out even today from back
then
that that became the first grown-up
uh example of my intuition of what
people were gonna do even though
smarter older wealthier more
accomplished people told me that they
weren't that was the first example if
I'm recapping it that I could point to
that said in a big boy version I was
right the incumbents were not and the
reason I say big boy prior to that I had
been doing you know a lot of things from
age 11 to 21 in sports cards comic books
collectible toys and I made a lot of
decisions during that 10-year window
that were counter-cultural to what
people thought I sold my entire baseball
card collection six months before the
market crashed and put it into comics
and collectible toys and those markets
exploded that was the first young boy
version of me being wildly right when
people were like why are you selling
cards it's the hottest and all of that
on both scenarios my friend came down to
me watching real people at scale instead
of trying to look at reports or or and
here's a big one for a lot of people on
this stream we're watching this video
um I didn't allow where I was making
money to dictate what I thought was
going to happen tomorrow
that's a big one I even though I was
making a lot of money a couple thousand
bucks a weekend in sports cards which by
the way still feels like a trillion I
still don't make that kind of money
um uh
I was like these people are not as
interested the fever's gone
people are talking more about Star Wars
and Spider-Man than Frank Thomas and Ken
Griffey I'm feeling something half my
class that was into cards isn't anymore
and it's not just because they're into
girls now like because they're still
into video games like I just and I do
that all the time it's how I do
everything to this day so in 96 that was
really betting the farm I asked my dad
for fifteen thousand dollars to build
winelibrary.com that felt like a
trillion just to give everyone context
on a small business for something that
seemed that'd be like asking a company
today a small business for like
15. 200 000 to build a metaverse right
it just seemed crazy the reason the.com
thing felt right whereas I wouldn't ask
a small business to build a better verse
for 200k today was I felt we were close
enough to people actually buying wine on
the internet and
um and and that's how I saw it and I
thought the internet thing was going to
be the biggest thing and uh and that was
because I was watching people not just
my friends but I noticed my friends mom
created email to email her son at
college and then I would listen and I
would hear that his mom said now she's
emailing with her sister and they're 47
and this is 1996. I'm like huh
like there's things I hear that people
do that very quickly my chemicals tell
me everyone's gonna do that not just
them and that was that example and that
has become the formula of my career
um listen to real people every day
don't let the way I'm making my money or
how I hope to make my money uh or my
success or my or my joy right some
people don't do things because they
don't like it it doesn't matter if I
don't like posting pictures on Instagram
people want to consume pictures on
Instagram my family took 25 photos in
our lifetime like we were a non-photo
family so Instagram was hard for me I
mean it the thought of taking a picture
is just to this day is foreign so
um that's how I think about it
almost a decade in around February 2006
give or take you you start my library TV
you're on YouTube pretty much daily for
around five years doing these long-form
episodics you on camera something that
people really weren't doing back I mean
this is months to maybe a year after
YouTube launches right so you're really
early in that game
um and you're doing it by yourself
you're you're consistently telling
people especially people who are posting
videos don't worry about your audience
don't worry about your likes don't worry
about your subscribers but what was this
experience like for you early on just
one guy talking to a camera back then
that was the biggest Mo that February
20th 2006 or 21st I always get confused
I think it's 21st that was um
that's probably the most significant
business days of my life right
um
I say business because I think so much
of what makes me work is realizing
family in real life is real life and
business even though I'm passionate
about it and people know I'm passionate
about is a very different is a game in a
lot of ways but that was one most it may
be top three most significant business
days in my life because I'm 30 years old
at this point and there's not a thought
in my mind that ever is thinking that
anybody on Earth is going to know who I
am outside of the wine and spirits
or I did have bigger aspirations but
business people right like business
stuff not like normal people knowing who
I am and that started the Journey of
normal people knowing who I am and it
started the Journey of me enjoying
communicating around complicated
subjects wine is very complex it's
extremely intimidating most of the
people watching right now don't drink as
much wine as they could be because it is
a little too intimidating they actually
think they have to know something to
even drink it which is something we
don't do in many other categories of
consumption so demystifying wine was a
huge thing for me because remember I'm
30 now I've been building this big
business for my dad for the last eight
years I want all my 20 year old friends
to care about it and none of them
brother could care about it there wasn't
20 year olds in the late 90s early 2000s
that could give a crap about wine it's
much cooler now the NBA I think has made
it cooler sideways the movie came along
a lot of things Two Buck Chuck a million
things happened that made wine more
interesting for 20 year olds but outside
of Highly wealth healthy generational
wealthy kids in their 20s almost no
other 20 year old paid attention to Wine
like real wine not like fronzy in a box
or something like that right so
I wanted to demystify it and I learned
so much the comments uh long-form video
creative I learned a lot about myself
which was I was a captivative
communicator and I later built on that
to create opportunities
um that was one of the great learning
and I'll tell you what I really learned
from episode one on and I we actually
just did this as a team we cut a clip
where I kind of I made the first episode
thinking I was going to do QVC a couple
minutes into the episode I realized I
was doing
1970s 1950s news when news used to be a
public service product not an
entertainment product and so I thought I
was going in with the most selfish
intent episode one of Wine Library TV
was built to sell wine on the internet I
was going to do QVC I'm gonna take wines
I'm gonna tell you what to buy
immediately within the first episode
within the first 10 minutes within the
first five minutes even I think you just
did the work right within the first five
minutes you could see me kind of look to
the side and I could and I didn't recall
when I did it but then the team just
showed me the video I I was like uh oh I
need to review wine
and bring them value not me value and I
got to tell them the truth because I
don't love every wine we sell and by the
way that doesn't mean that I'm right
because everyone has a different palette
and it took the show to the Stratos
where people were like people were
flabbergasted that I was the owner of
this store selling these wines and
telling people not to buy the wine
my dad is still my dad is still
flabbergasted I did that
you uh you were talking about Instagram
before and kind of the difficulties you
were having you're all over every social
media platform always and you you're
really good at differentiating the
content per platform so how do you go
about differentiating her audience and
and I hope there's an actress is there
is there a specific platform that's
delivered the strongest return on your
investment and time and resources for
you the reason that the last I'll go to
the latter one here's why it's so hard
for my career and this is why I'm so
humbled to be here this is what's good
about having receipts I was early and
fast and hard on all of them I was a big
YouTuber in oh six seven I was one of
the first people to have a million
followers on Twitter in 2007 eight right
Instagram Tick Tock like when when Tick
Tock was musically I was making content
for Madison Avenue let alone my fan base
of like get on this so they've all been
massive for me because I land grabbed
the attention early by not only being
there early but being good at the
creative contextual for it to your point
my garage sale videos on Tick Tock are
doing much better than they're doing on
Facebook because there's a lot of 15 16
year olds that do want to make an extra
50 bucks and learn the game and and so
they love that they think it's silly
they think it's crazy that somebody who
you seemingly has some wealth on paper
still wants the garage sale so they find
that funny and that's interesting there
whereas on LinkedIn I'm making content
for this audience right I want to talk I
I'm a very weird agency owner I kind of
root I wouldn't say root that's
um I definitely don't feel like I'm
competing with akqa or or widening
Kennedy or Crispin or Bill from Horizon
I hope he builds a TR like I kind of
think everyone who's good is going to
get theirs I don't think like yeah sure
I may lose a pitch to droga but but
droga's not stopping Vayner from being
successful and Boehner's not stopping
droga from being successful and so I
have a very interesting relationship
with my content on LinkedIn of my
teammates actually struggle sometimes
when they think I'm giving away too much
too soon
and and I just don't see it that way a I
think all of our companies have
different cultures so it's hard to you
know as hard as it is for me to buy
outdoor media because it's not in my DNA
it's not so easy to be prolific and
contextual social creative for a shop
that was built on making television so a
I think it's hard for all of us to
incorporate things but B even if they
could I think Karma goes a long way so
when I'm making LinkedIn I'm thinking
about Madison Avenue CEOs
and trying to leave some Legacy on maybe
helping them and like over a drink a can
in five years them saying thank you
which would make me feel good
on Tick Tock I'm thinking about 15 year
old entrepreneurs on Instagram I'm
thinking about 25 to 40 year old you
know like kind of like
I call it like in Pocket like just kind
of like the masses right now so like
they all work so differently and I think
about it this way you right you
consuming my content you yourself you're
the same person you consuming my content
on LinkedIn you are in a different
psychological place when you decide to
consume content on LinkedIn then when
you're on tick tock on Tick Tock you are
in the mindset of passive
entertainment
you're you're channel surfing
on LinkedIn you're probably in a place
of business oriented objectives either
learning or networking I've got to show
up differently just like I have to show
up differently for my kids then I have
to do for my buddies on Sunday at the
Jets game I got to be parking lot
tailgate jet band Gary there and I gotta
be father Gary you know hours earlier
the day before and then I got to be this
carry here and for my mom I'm son Gary
and so I don't understand how this
industry continues to underestimate the
power of context
and overvalue subjective content
let's talk executive Gary then right so
you mentioned all the creatives in the
agencies
vaynermedia has had tons of brands that
you've worked with and a lot of really
memorable campaigns
when a brand exec comes into your
offices for the very first time for one
of those creative meetings what's the
first thing you say to them or or the
first question that you ask right out
the gate
um that's a fun question the the first
thing I'll say the first the thing I
always ask them is what what are we
trying to accomplish and are you scoring
that in a common sense real life way or
are you doing that in a corporate way so
that's the big big elephant in the room
with us which is like your brand lift
study can't be the kpi because those are
flawed like like what are we doing here
um Impressions on social media is not a
good proxy the cost of your you know of
of The Impressions on digital is not the
kpi but we continue to make these
mistakes in the industry the thing I say
to them is Vayner is the biggest Enigma
in this industry because we sell a
process to get to the best ideas not we
sell the best ideas that is Michael that
is very different my friend
this is not we have great casting and
you know and Cat and Jackie one of my
favorite creative teams Nadia a new
unbelievable creative Aaron Howe who's
crushing in in uh or in in LA or Vijay
who's doing who just moved from our APAC
office to to the UK emea these are
incredibly talented people
and and this industry all these
incredible shops that I admire widen and
droga and 72 and sunny loaded with
Incredible talent to come up with ideas
but I think the industry has not been
fair in realizing that the process to
get to these ideas and how they're
distributed have not been effective now
for a decade against the cost that was
Associated to make that happen
and so we sell a process the thing I say
to them my friend is if you come to work
with Vayner it's not about the it's
about the work it's about the ideas but
we don't do that subjectively up front
in boardrooms we have a process to do
that with consumers in Social that
extract them from that process that is
the upside down part of this industry
that we do very differently and as you
can imagine that means people either
really like it or really struggle with
it and we're very empathetic and we've
been very patient with the industry the
last 13 years I do think that we're
starting to build some momentum because
the truth is undefeated
you go into kind of the personal brand
space a bit also there's products kind
of associated with your name so whether
it's empathy wines or the K-Swiss you
know sneaker line what's most important
to you when you're taking a product and
you're putting your name on it
that I believe in what I'm selling
yeah you know I think I've been a great
salesman my whole life because I don't
sell things that I don't believe in
you know I believe that empathy wines is
a dramatically better 20 wine than most
20 Wines in the market I know that
because I know the sources of the grapes
and things that nature but I also think
that Maggie who I do is sitting here she
may like a seven dollar wine better than
empathy that's okay
you know but I think
and this is actually like I'll be honest
with you this is actually where I've had
a little bit of I don't have a whole lot
of problems with the people in the
industry right even though we were like
Renegades and people would Razz me I
always understood but the one thing that
did always bother me is
you know after four glasses of wine
mainly Rose at can a lot of these people
who would publicly post nasty things
about me or Razz me in meetings would
kind of get just Tipsy enough to say
you're on to something or you're right
and I would ask them it was always
that's always so nice so I'm incredibly
I try to be remarkably gracious in those
moments
because I think all the things that have
worked for me is the byproduct of my
parents and the luck of my DNA draw so I
don't get too high on my garyvee Supply
I I say to them I'm like why are you
selling something you don't believe in
and I know the answer people have lives
and they have this is what where they
find themselves and they have mortgages
and kids like you know you know I get it
but there's so many people that could be
doing other things outside of Madison
Avenue now with us I think there'll be a
lot of copycatting of us in the next
decade so there'll be Alternatives but
like
you know what's most important to me
that I believe in it like I believe that
I am going to build
one of the most significant intellectual
properties of all time I really believe
that I really believe that practical
peacock can be like Lisa Simpson one day
I really believe that and so as you can
imagine that gives me the energy to go
so hard to believe like I'm really into
it and so you've got to believe in what
you you know I believe the case with
sneaker at that 40 price ran is as good
of an alternative as another sneaker and
if you choose to like believe in the
mission statement of the sneakers which
is be kind be practical you know if you
see something in front of you that you
want it's going to take work ethic not
burning out but work ethic you know and
things like that so I always believe in
this stuff I sell the garyvee stuff I
believe that my mom is the greatest Mom
of all time I believe that I believe
other moms have come along that tie my
mom because they also are 100 about
their children but also not delusional
and keep it in this great mix of like
self-esteem building but not entitlement
building which is impossible trust me I
don't think I'm good at it with my kids
I get it it's hard
um so I believe in the things that I
talk about patience and kindness but I
do believe in tenacity and and
competition so I live in this world and
I'll use America I live in this world
that is desperately trying to make the
world about red or blue and every day
pushes more red or blue and I know the
answer is purple
right look at me I I as a marketing
proxy I think the Super Bowl is the
number one ad in marketing the best ad
you can buy
right even though I'm very anti-other
television
right right
I'm gonna get destroyed if I don't ask
you about nfts people are just gonna
they're gonna rip them people are
waiting for you to talk about it right
crypto nfts they were on the edge of
their seats waiting for you and you kind
of you took your time a little bit right
kind of pause and said just hold on like
give me a little time and feel it out
but all roads led to the friends right
yeah so what I really like about it and
what I think people like about it is
that it's not just a a collectible photo
right there's application there's access
to it because how it kind of came to be
and also what are you most excited about
with nfts beyond their current
implementation right now
pets.com was worth 85 billion dollars
in 1999 or eight or seven or two
thousand or some staggering number I
might be slightly off in 85 but like the
number was just
incomprehendable
and because of that and all the other
companies they all went to zero except
for
Amazon PayPal right couple that were
there
eBay that excites me about nfts right
now
one of the reasons I haven't been
completely torched in society is because
I made ungodly amounts of content last
year around this time saying 99 of nfts
were going to go to zero
even though I was the macro Advocate and
I'll get to that in a minute in the
micro I saw the behavior was Deja Vu of
Internet stocks what am I most excited
about is that chewy.com is one of the
biggest companies Brewing right
huge business why because it's pets.com
20 years later
the internet was the biggest thing the
companies that were built on 96 789 got
over valued the nfts are going to be one
of the biggest consumer technology
shifts ever
a decentralized server that can
fully and 100
guarantee transactional Authority
in a decentralized way
is going to do the transactions what the
internet did for communication
it just needs a few minutes to get there
it's a it's a you know and so uh what am
I most excited about I'm most excited
about Madison Square Garden over there
that my tickets are not QR codes or a
piece of paper like I had for kygo last
night
the paper it's going to be a nft kygo
limited edition thing and I'll get in
and then in 20 years
um I can sell it for 19 bucks and that's
cool and MSG and kygo will get a piece
of the royalty or kygo and MSG will say
it's a 25th Anniversary Concert and
everybody who still has the original nft
from 25 years ago gets to come in three
hours early and do a special like people
don't understand that once the
infrastructure exists the best companies
and the best actors can do the best
things we just lived through the first
year where the worst actors did things
everybody tried to sell a quick scam and
like everybody was so much money gets
you confused real fast and so people are
coming in quick quick but what I'm most
excited about is actually
the blockchain will allow for incredible
behavior from the issuers if they have
good intent one of the reasons I did
vcon
for three years in a row to launch
befriends was I knew that if there was a
lot of volatility in the value of the V
friend that the original issuing price
was worth going to Beacon for three
years
and that's why my project is doing well
because people actually have other
utilitarian value in the smart contract
it's not just a collectible now my work
for the next 50 years is to make these
characters so famous that people do want
to buy that original nfts no different
than buying the first edition of Batman
comic book or the first Charizard
Pokemon or you know and so I come from a
collector background I'm going to work
very hard in making toys comic books
books movies TV shows pillowcases candy
cereal vitamins you know like I'm
showing my cards and what's most
exciting for me Michael is through my
work with me friends I'm going to be
able to show our industry
like contemporary marketing works
and so it's it's fun for me the reason I
always have businesses like empathy like
my dad's wine store like be friends is I
want to stay sharp as an operator
so that I can give the best advice to
our clients I take a lot of Pride that
unlike my contemporaries who are CEOs of
agencies I'm actually making content
every day I actually do have a personal
brand I do run businesses that run the
marketing that I sell
you've always been one to embrace
mistakes yes um you talk about this what
would you say is the
biggest mistake that you've made that's
led to the most positive lesson learned
the way I ran vaynermedia from 2000 what
are we on 22 19. from
2015 to 19. I I sensed that we were
gonna get big and I just started hiring
unlimited people from the outside and
did a terrible job putting those players
in a position to succeed because of my
lack of Candor I actually hate
negativity which confuses some people
because they find me aggressive I get
excited because I turn a little bit into
like a wrestling Promoter on video but
like like I think a Macho Man Randy
Savage but I actually am incredibly
non-confrontational which is actually a
strong weakness of leaders
um in public Persona again you know
against what I don't think the industry
is doing I'm quite confrontational but
like to my to Maggie or Andrew or Dustin
no way and that was a weakness so I
hired a ton of people from the outside
I didn't create training for them to
teach the Vayner way and I was incapable
of giving them feedback as they were
taking us further and further away
in the name of let's see what the
outside world does so I can test it and
then adjust for vaynermedia 3.0
so what so why is that the answer in
2019 I'm like uh oh this is getting away
from me I feel like we're just like a
bad version of all these people I admire
we're not ourselves
and social is getting more important not
less
damn it I need to like go all the way
back to 2009 Gary
and I started doing that and then
covered hit which gave me a ton of time
to lean into all my leaders
and it is now profound I mean I am
downright scared how well positioned we
are for the next
wave of how big brands are going to
Market both and how they spend their
media and do their creative and it all
happened because of the mistake of 15 to
19 and it was a catastrophic mistake we
grew every year from 15 to 19. we just
weren't
us or me we weren't me yeah and and so
we're the most me right now that we've
been through since 2011. that's the
truth Vayner today and we're at scale
is the most me since 2011 and boy oh boy
do I see it showing up in people's
happiness uh in Our Winning a business
in our retention of business and I'm I'm
really excited and and what's way cooler
Michael than 2009 or 2011 is the world
is ready to understand the biggest truth
which is the elephant in the room in
Madison Avenue which is brand is built
in Social through scaled relevance to
many more consumer segmentations than
television and programmatic digital has
been able to afford us and that the
creative variable to put into those
pipes and a modern comms plan not based
on Impressions and grps is required and
that is an atomic bomb to what we've
been taught for the last 40 years and I
believe that I am stunned by how many
CMOS and more importantly CEOs of these
companies are starting to get to that
realization and that is going to be the
great reset of this industry I think of
the next decade
take notes everyone
um you mentioned negativity before and I
kind of want to go back to we have like
one or two more questions and I really
wanted to ask you this one because
you're a really polarizing figure and
you've also said people will have very
strong opinions about you either way and
you're really good with the negative
right there's the positive I love you
there's the negative you're very
empathetic with people you always talk
about that have you always been that way
and if not how did you get to that point
and then most importantly for me isn't
even and I do want to focus on you know
the people who are saying these but I
also want to talk about imposter
syndrome because I think even worse than
that is kind of that self-negativity
also how do you get through that too
I've
this is all you know I'm glad I brought
her up earlier because it's the answer
like I don't know what else to say like
everything that I've done wrong I take
full blame for and everything I've done
right I give full credit to my parents
and my circumstance and America at the
right time for a Russian boy like it
just all like and and what does that all
lead to deep gratitude look at all these
things that I had nothing to do with
that I believe are the pillars of my
happiness and joy
how do you not
lead with gratitude so when people are
mad at me
a 90 of it is in our industry 99 of it's
Crystal Clear to why they would say it
it's affecting their personal finances
like if you know of course if garyvee
goes and does an a a and is cursed
leading
like that TV commercials are overpriced
and your entire agency buys or makes TV
commercials and I'm abrasive like I'm in
my Chris Rock Macho Man like I you know
if I'm sitting there and I'm that person
of course this is not gonna land
who does he think he is he's got no clue
naive you know like I get it whatever I
don't like him what I'm incredibly proud
of is many people who've publicly and
privately razzed me
when I get to actually know them and
spend an hour with them
we have an incredible joyful
relationship going forward and I'm proud
of that I'm proud of who I am because I
think it's an indication of my parenting
and I'm empathetic when people don't
like me because I have strong
convictions and I think the industry is
underperforming for what I I deeply
believe that the majority of agencies
are too expensive to the clients for
what they're providing I believe that to
be true I I don't think that anybody's
bad I don't think these are bad people I
don't think they're not smart I actually
think some of them are incredibly smart
at the tippy tops to why they're doing
it
um but yeah that's my belief system I
don't know how not to articulate it but
yeah you know and an imposter syndrome
like
I don't in Reverse I don't believe my
own hype I don't think I'm special when
you know some people like you're a scam
artist and other people you're the goat
I don't believe either because neither
are true and I just stay in my lane and
do my thing and try to do the best I can
and and Michael look this is an
important moment for me like an
interview like this is completely
predicated on being right
right I don't get invited to this
interview if I haven't been right for
the last 20 years
so whether I try to defend myself
or I succumb to people's negativity or
positivity it's completely irrelevant
the receipts are going to speak for
themselves
the receipts are going to speak so
either I'm right or I'm wrong and so I
can live with that and I try not to be
wrong
which is why I do things that are
controversial you think the nft land
liked me when I was in the height of the
height of the height last summer saying
99 are going to zero I got bombarded by
people like yo why are you what do you
like you're supposed to be the biggest
Advocate I am the biggest Advocate but
I'm not an advocate for a JPEG that has
no utility you know and it's not a jpeg
because that's the internet and image
I'm not for a collectible that has no
Affinity yet
being worth fifty thousand dollars
um for a Spider-Man rare thing that's
done work for 50 years be worth 50. I
understand 16 16 to 60 000 people want
it
so I will speak whatever I believe and
let the receipts fall where they may I'm
not worried about somebody's opinion
about me when it's completely predicated
on their own self-interest
well keep speaking your truth I and
everyone appreciates it I wish I could
speak to you forever we we're out of
time I could have spoken forever but
um thank you for doing that thank you
honor and a pleasure I think something
that you say that's so important is that
the most important thing to be incoming
wildly successful that people don't
think about is just being a nice I
believe it I can be successful and and
can I be nice for a second Michael
yeah this industry has some of the
nicest smartest most creative people
I've ever met
the consolidation and the Deep ideology
of the past is suppressing a lot of it
all my jargon I'm going to be successful
regardless by closing me like I have one
before I got here
I won before I got here I am gonna be
here and I'm gonna do my thing but I
desperately want other people to win as
well and a lot of the energy I bring to
this industry is because I think it's a
beautiful industry but I think you know
what I'm about to say has a lot of truth
there's just not enough people that love
it in our industry
the the happiness meter of agency life
day to day isn't High Enough and I play
outside of this world and see other
Industries other sectors it can be
better
and I think it starts with how we
interact with each other competitively
how we interact with our team uh
eliminating fear of client feedback and
and just just we just have to do some
different things we we can get there
this industry can get there we can be
more creative we can be happier we can
be much more civil to each other I think
it could be great and I um and I I fight
for that foreign
[Music]